PhD student and I'm now kind of entering
my final phase of my PhD I still have
about one and a half years left which
really stresses me out and actually
throughout my PhD I accumulated a lot of
papers on zotero but of course I don't
always read these papers I think this is
a continuous struggle of every PhD
student that I know but I fought a
really good challenge for me to set for
myself this week is to try to read 50
papers so that means about 10 papers a
day I
also have a big reading challenge coming
up or you have to write a paper watch
this video and I will give a lot of tips
along the way of how I structure reading
how I kind of accumulate ideas how I do
a little bit more loose reading or how I
try to go through a paper as quickly as
possible so let's get straight into it
so the first thing that I did is I
accumulated all of the papers that I had
to read in one folder in zotero as I was
scrolling through all these papers I
kind of felt super duper overwhelmed and
I was just like where do I start reading
all of these papers because as you know
reading one scientific paper usually
takes me about two hours to really
understand truly what the paper is about
and it can take even longer if it's
about a new subject and especially if I
read all of the words in the scientific
paper so that's why there are definitely
different strategies to reading a paper
of course the thing you need when you
start a challenge like this is kind of
like a supernatural Aid so something
like Chachi PT for example could help so
I asked a GPT of course to make me a
schedule for reading 50 papers and I had
to do it in the evening because
throughout the day I do actually have to
work on my normal science work and
that's kind of the struggle of being a
PhD student you have to do your work and
you have to read at the same time but I
asked HTTP to make me a schedule every
day from 5 until 10 that I could read
about 10 papers so that meant I have
about half an hour per paper to read the
paper and maybe you're thinking how can
you read an entire paper in half an hour
so I will show you how I do it so the
thing is that for scientific articles
there are actually a quite a few methods
to reading the paper and I think if you
read papers you gather new ideas you
actually don't have to read the papers
in depth I think if you're doing it to
learn a new technique or if you really
want to follow the ideas in the paper
and apply them yourselves it's sometimes
a bit better to do a deep read but to do
a more shallow type of reading it is
definitely a different technique so the
first thing that you do is usually I
skim the abstract to see if the paper is
even relevant because a lot of times the
title maybe says something but even
reading the apps tracks we can kind of
see that oh this is not what I'm looking
for then the next thing I do is I read
the conclusion because the conclusion
just says the what kind of findings the
papers found and if this is relevant for
you and after the conclusion I go to the
figures immediately and I try to
understand the figures without reading
the text I think if you understand a
topic quite well you should be able to
understand the figures without having
read the text and if you don't
describing two things or you don't have
enough knowledge on this topic and you
have to reach the accompanying results
or it could be that the Figures were
badly made which is also something that
happens quite a lot and after I've
looked at the results I usually skim
read the method section and that's
because the method section for me is
usually the most and the least
interesting it's the most interesting if
I decide that the paper is super
relevant for my PhD and if I want to
emulate something for example that
they've done but it's the least
interesting in the sense that sometimes
it just has a lot of details a lot of
jargon that you don't necessarily need
to have in your brain so I think that's
really the point where you can win or
lose time so let's get into reading 10
more papers thank you
[Music]
so I also wanted to give you a list of
tools so throughout the week of course
I've used a lot of tools that I
personally use for reading scientific
articles and in this video I want to
introduce you to pop
so also I want to give you a list of
tools that I always use when reading
papers and I think they can be really
helpful if you're also on a reading
challenge or just in general for your
PhD so the first thing that you really
need is a reference manager so reference
managers are very diverse you can use
zotero medley or endnote and they help
you organize and manage your references
and they allow you to save organize your
papers generate biographies and annotate
your readings and I started with medley
and then changed to zotero not really
with a specific reason but I just liked
a little bit more how zotero looked and
something that I really like that you
can do with zotero is create these kind
of tags so for example I created this
tag that is just called red and it also
has this green color such that I can
kind of track overtime which papers I
have read and which papers I still need
to read another thing that I personally
really like to use lately is to use
summarizing tools and of course there's
no better summarizing tool than chat GPT
I think using chechi PT in an academic
setting is definitely something you have
to do with caution but to summarize a
paper or summarize an introduction or to
re-explain a certain part of the text I
think chechi PT can be really good for
that so you give it a little part of the
text and you ask it for a five note
summary for example that you can paste
in your notion or another type of tool
that you use to track your notes and
that way you can create these kind of
summary overviews of all the papers that
you have read and then if ever you need
to reference something or you just want
to know a little bit what that paper was
about you can just look at your summary
notes two other things that I kind of
want to talk about and that's more to
find papers is to use Scopes so scopus
is a really nice tool to find papers but
I think it's also really nice that you
can create these alerts for certain
authors that you like so for example a
few people that I know in the field that
publish a lot I have created alerts for
them and then every week or every month
on my email I get a dedicated email to
the papers that they have published that
month and that's a really good way to
passively stay updated with the latest
research another way that I've talked
about many times in previous videos of
how to stay updated with the research is
to use Twitter and Twitter is just I
think for researchers one of the best
social media platforms even though some
controversial things have been happening
on Twitter I still think it's the only
platform but I personally know that
really allows you to follow some of your
favorite researchers in the field and
almost all researchers that I know if
they have any type of preprints they
will post it on Twitter and also
something that I find really nice is
that a lot of professors are very much
against the page services that you have
to provide for papers that they don't
really agree with some of the paywalls
that certain journals have and such they
will provide you usually links to their
papers for free on websites such as bio
archives such that students that don't
have the money to read expensive
journals you can also access their
papers
[Music]
so at the end of the week I have read
these many papers and I'm actually
really proud of how far I've come I
think in general in doing your PhD it's
really hard to balance the amount of
output you have to produce and the
amount of input you have to consume and
for me what really works is to sometimes
divide my weeks into weeks that I do a
little bit more reading and weeks that I
do a little bit more programming or some
type of teaching and I think in my mind
I just if I notice that I really don't
have some kind of knowledge on a subject
or I really have to push a little bit
more towards another subject or really
have to learn about something I do
usually try to take some time off to
really spend on acquiring that knowledge
and really updating my level of
knowledge on the field and I think this
can be really overwhelming and I do know
people that have structured it
differently for example some of my
friends read one paper every morning and
that way they have read about five
papers every week because of course you
take Saturday and Sunday off but yeah
let me know if you have any tips or
tricks of how you divide your work
between Reading Writing studying all of
these things that you have to do as a
student and also let me know if you have
any Curiosities that you have about
Neuroscience because I definitely in the
future I want to make a few more videos
about Neuroscience as well and otherwise
see you next week bye